hi guys I'm Titus and I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm ready to answer your
questions while playing with puppies my
god I can't I don't know this is
pleasure or torture I'm ovulating my
system answer these questions
would you be roommates with someone like
Kimmy Schmidt in real life hell no hi
baby hi I like my personal space and I
love my private time and she has no
boundaries so that would never work the
puppies are always welcome right what is
your dream role I don't know that I have
a dream role guys I'll tell you what I
do dream about though is always being
able to communicate however that
manifests itself cooking the
conversation a great bowel movement
that's my dream the day that I can't do
that effectively is the day that I
should stop but that's my dream role to
be able to communicate with you guys and
to make you feel satisfied that's the
truth who would play you in a movie
based on your life me I just realized
what you've been doing for the past 15
minutes just not on my shoes these
things cause a lot of money diva have
you ever missed a subtle joke in the
show oh all the time
like I I rarely get the jokes no joke
like I have to reread the script over
and over and over again because the
jokes are so clever and they go by so
fast what is the biggest thing you value
about yourself well that's a good
question Oh God I don't care what people
think about me I never have I value
people's opinions
don't care what they think as long as I
can go to sleep at night that have this
conscience clear and as long as my maker
is pleased that's a wrap
how do you feel about the cast of
unbreakable kimmy schmitt a rare is it
that you walk into a set and you
experience a kismet absorbs and Ellie
Kimber was so warm and so generous and
so patient with me and Jane and I knew
each other from the theater and from 30
lakh she's like my my naughty sister I
love those people and I cannot believe
it's gone by so fast
hopefully Netflix is forever online is
forever so hopefully you'll have it
forever what is your favorite song to
dance to when you're alone that's a
great question I don't know that I have
a favorite song to dance to
but I guess lately if I can answer it
that way
I've been jamming out to happy again by
uh Pharrell is happy with what I
listened to you on repeat what I wanted
to stay in a high conscious states that
I would get this job when I got this job
so I I listen to happy and I thought
should reintroduce that back into my
world right guys do you want to read one
exactly what's your favorite part about
playing Titus and unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt I don't think he's he and I
share much in common
outside of I love a musical theater and
Diana Ross I love that what comes up
comes out there's no filter and in a
world where I feel people in an attempt
to find their place from their platform
become overly sensitive that Titus
Andromeda gave two weeks and told you
exactly what he thought
and it felt so good to be able to do
that as someone else because I cannot do
that this is so cute like I can't
and what do ya'll say it how many
different colors could be considered too
many in one sweater more than one where
can we hear and see more of you please
do an album movie podcast or something
that's so funny well first of all thank
you so much for wanting to see anything
that has to do with me I have a lot of
things in the works oh now that sounds
so ambiguous but it's true and it takes
forever to get anything done here in New
York City and in Hollywood but I can
assure you that you will be satiated
when it happens and you will appreciate
the fact that it took me so long to do
it but there's a big old concert coming
tuned I can't tell you where and I can't
tell you what but you're gonna be
excited about that and I am doing an
album and if all goes well it'll be out
in May this has been so much ride Thank
You BuzzFeed I wish all of my interviews
were like this and thank you to the fans
for lighting I love to answer your
questions you guys are very thoughtful
and be sure to watch us in January on
January 25th more unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt I'm random a chemist right now
and forever
[Music]